- [Voiceover] This is
a quote by a physicist
as a comment on one of
his experimental results.
He said, about his experiment, he said,
"It was as if you fired a 15-inch shell
"at a piece of tissue paper,
"and it came back and hit you."
So let's talk about his
experiment and what he was doing.
Rutherford, at the time, had
been doing a lot of research
on radioactivity.
He was friends with Marie
Curie and her husband, Pierre.
And he had done a lot of studies
looking at the different
kinds of reactivity,
and more specifically, he
was curious at this time
about alpha particles,
which are,
actually, at the time, he didn't know
what they were, but we now know they are
Helium, 2+ nuclei.
So that means we have two
protons in the nucleus,
since it's Helium, and
it also has two neutrons.
And it doesn't have any
electrons, and thus,
it has a 2+ charge.
So what Rutherford did,
he took a piece of radium
and he put it inside a lead box.
And the lead box had a
small hole in it on one side
so that the radioactive alpha particles
could come out of that hole in
the direction that he wanted.
And then, he shot the alpha particles
at a piece of gold foil,
a very thin piece of gold foil.
And he was curious to see if
he could learn a little bit
about the structure of the
atom using this experiment.
So, if we look back at our quote,
we would say that our
alpha particles here,
the alpha particles are the bullets
that are coming out of our
alpha particle gun, and
gold foil is our tissue paper.
And we have these pretty fast and massive
alpha particles that we're shooting at it.
But why was Rutherford
expecting that to happen here?
It's not necessarily straightforward,
at least to me, why you would
think these alpha particles
would just go straight
through the gold foil.
So what Rutherford, at
the time, was doing was,
he was testing the plum pudding model.
So this is pretty early
in history, where we,
we being scientists way back then,
knew that J. J. Thomson,
another physicist,
had just discovered electrons.
So we knew the atom,
the atom had these particles
in it that were small,
that were really small,
we knew that they were
less than one percent the
mass of a Hydrogen atom,
so way smaller than an atom.
And we knew they were negatively charged,
so I'm going to call them electrons
'cause we know they're electrons now.
And so J. J. Thomson knew
that electrons existed
based on his experimental results,
and he proposed, based on his results,
that an atom looks something
like a plum pudding.
And if you don't know
what a plum pudding is,
because maybe you're not British,
or maybe you just don't like dessert,
you can also imagine it
looking something like
a chocolate chip cookie.
So we have these little
negatively-charged particles
that are stuck inside the atom,
but most of the atom is made up of
a positively-charged soup.
And this was mainly because
the atom overall has to be neutral.
Scientists knew that atoms were neutral,
so there had to be something there
to cancel out the negative
charge of the electron.
So because Rutherford was starting
with this in his mind
for what the gold atoms looked like,
he could actually do
mathematical predictions
on what the alpha particles would do.
And what he predicted was that
they would just go straight through.
You can use physics equations
to look at the electric field
that's generated by this
positively-charged soup,
and it turns out that the field,
because the charge is spread
out all over the atom,
the field is very weak.
And so, what he thought would happen
was that all the particles
would just go straight through
and then, occasionally, one
might be bent a little bit.
Since we do have
a positively-charged soupy atom,
depending on where the
alpha particle goes through,
he thought you might see a
little bit of deflection,
but mostly, they should
go straight through.
And I guess we started with a spoiler,
'cause we know that he didn't
quite get what he expected.
So what exactly did Rutherford see?
Well, he shot his alpha
particles at his tissue paper,
and he saw most of the
particles go straight through,
just as he expected.
In fact, he saw almost all the particles
go straight through.
He saw a couple of them
be deflected a little bit,
so they got deflected off their path
maybe about one degree, so barely enough
to be able to see it.
And, if he had not been a curious chemist,
we would maybe still think, right now,
that this is what an atom looks like.
But luckily, Rutherford was
a very thorough chemist,
and he also thought,
it might be interesting
to detect whether
particles came, not just here,
he didn't just put a detector screen here,
he put a detector screen
that went all the way around.
So, all the way around,
almost all the way around,
giving enough space for the
alpha particles to go in.
And he was being really careful here,
'cause he didn't really
expect to see anything
right around here or here or here,
or really anywhere except for here.
But it turned out that for every
one in...
one in 20,000
alpha particles,
or some crazy-tiny number like that,
for every one in 20,000 alpha particles,
he saw the particles hit the gold foil
and bounce back.
And that's crazy, right?
That's exactly what you don't expect
when you hit a piece of
tissue paper with a bullet.
So the first thing he did, I think,
was not go, hmmm, this is really crazy,
we just won a Nobel Prize here.
I'm pretty sure the
first thing he did was,
this is weird.
And then he probably checked
his experimental results.
And he tried to repeat it,
and he checked everything to make sure
nothing was going wrong,
and it turned out that, yes,
something was actually happening.
This one in 20,000 alpha
particles was real.
So what did this mean?
This meant that we needed
a new atomic model.
We had to explain, somehow,
that a tiny fraction
of the alpha particles
was getting bounced back.
So how did he do this?
He knew there was something in the atom
that was tiny,
massive, and positively charged.
And he knew that it had to be tiny
because not very many alpha particles
interacted with it, 'cause most of them
went straight through.
He knew that it had to be massive
and positively charged
because, well, the electrons
are really small, and
most of the particles
went straight through.
So whatever these particles
were interacting with
had to be very small but really heavy,
which is how they bounced right back.
So he made a new
model of the atom that incorporated
these requirements.
And what he said was that
there must be something in
there with these properties,
which we now call the nucleus.
And it's really tiny,
in fact he was able to
calculate, not exactly.
He was able to calculate
approximately how big it was
based on how many alpha particles hit it,
and he said it was approximately
1/10,000
of the volume of the atom.
And then, what else do we have?
We know we have this nucleus,
which is positively-charged
and tiny and massive.
And then we also have our electrons.
And then what's the
rest of the atom doing?
Based on all of this, that
means most of the atom
is actually empty space.
Since the electrons are really small
and the nucleus only takes up
1/10,000 of the radius,
the rest of that space
is all just nothing,
which is kind of crazy, so
based on this particular model
that Rutherford made next,
he was able to explain his results.
He was able to explain that
most of the alpha particles
just went straight through,
and then every now and then,
an alpha particle would come
really close to the nucleus,
and then that would get
defected a little bit,
and even more rare, an
alpha particle may hit
a nucleus straight on,
and then it would get
bounced off because the
nucleus is super-heavy
and because it is positively charged,
so it would repel the
positively-charged alpha particle.
Rutherford called this particular model,
or we call it now, I'm
not sure which, actually,
he called it the Nuclear Model.
This actually looks pretty similar
to the modern picture of the atom
that most people think of.
There's a lot of questions that
are still not answered here,
like what exactly the electrons are doing.
Or where are they?
Where are the electrons?
But because Rutherford
proposed this new model,
other scientists were able
to design new expiriments
to test it.
And not very long afterward,
we had a pretty good picture
of what was going on
on the level of the atom.